le déficit de la sécurité sociale un
nouveau plan pour éviter les dérapages
les premières mesures visent certains
spécialistes et les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques députés sénateurs
d'accord à l'unanimité ou presque pour
changer le statut de la nouvelle
calédonie qui devrait l'amener
éventuellement à terme à l'indépendance
incendies continuent de progresser en
floride 180 mille hectares détruits
dernier rempart les hélicoptères
bombardiers d'eau qui prennent tous les
risques pour combattre le feu sous dans
une guerre religieuse et civile oublier
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
chrétiens risquent de mourir de faim si
le régime islamiste de khartoum empêche
l'acheminement des secours
reportage dans ce journal le dernier
carré des demi finalistes de la coupe du
monde france croatie brésil pays bas
invité de ce journal plaie dont nous
attendons les commentaires et les
pronostics
madame monsieur bonsoir du rire aux
larmes pour plusieurs centaines de
milliers de jeunes candidats au bac
c'était aujourd'hui le jour des
résultats reçus collés ou oral de
rattrapage pour tous en tout cas une
journée difficile jean bernard schmidt
reynou poissonnier elle l'a fait là
aussi
ilo fin de l' angoisse pour les 350
mille candidats au bac général c'était
aujourd'hui le jour fatidique des
résultats dans ce centre d'examen 300
candidats en série scientifique verdict
80% d'amis dès le premier tour
de quoi fanfaronner banalité bon c'était
sûr non franchement c'est trop de chance
de quoi aussi se rassurer on ag l'âge
d'être d'être leur mère qui pour la
majorité les vacances commencent mais il
y a comme chaque année le lot de recalés
ou ceux qui ont droit aux oraux de
rattrapage
pas question de les laisser tomber tous
les conseils sont bons pour choisir les
matières à repasser en fonction des
coefficients sont plus sympa cool donc
quelques ténors de 7,7 bon c'est peu
efficientes pour les moins bons les
moins chanceux les oraux débute demain
matin et se termineront vendredi et pour
juger de la qualité du cru 81,18 du bac
il faudra attendre la fin de la semaine
prochaine un nouveau plan pour tenter de
résorber le déficit de la sécurité
sociale la ministre de la solidarité
martine aubry et le ministre de la santé
bernard kouchner ont présenté
aujourd'hui un ensemble de mesures
d'économies pour l'assurance maladie à
hauteur de 3 milliards de francs pour
cette année le plan juppé définitivement
enterrée il faut établir de nouveaux
objectifs les premières mesures visent
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques et
parmi les spécialistes les radiologues
yannick letranchant michel lossent
dépenser moins en soignant mieux les
ministres passent mais la formule reste
pourtant martine aubry et bernard
kouchner se défend de mettre en place un
énième plan d'urgence
il préfère parler de programme d'action
nuance les dépenses de santé dérape il
faut trouver des remèdes
les médecins dépensier sont
particulièrement visés
non je prendrai des mesures avant la fin
du mois de juillet en concertation avec
les professions qui ont dérapé
les radiologues les biologistes qui ont
une grande habitude de la négociation je
suis sûr qu'on y arrivera les dentistes
pour lesquelles nous avons repoussé une
dernière revalorisation et l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui a largement profité
je dirais les dépenses ces derniers mois
l'objectif trouver 3 milliards de francs
d'économies 1 milliard 5 à 2 milliards
rien que pour l'industrie du médicament
450 millions chez les radiologues et à
peu près la même chose pour les
laboratoires d'analysés le système de
sanctions financières pour les médecins
dépensier compter dans le plan juppé est
abrogé il sera remplacé par un autre
dispositif qui se veut plus objectif et
plus simple l'ambition du gouvernement
freiner le dérapage dans un premier
temps et ramener le déficit à 4
milliards 900 millions de francs à la
fin de cette année on le sait la
communauté médicale n'est pas homogène
il ya les généralistes les spécialistes
réaction après les premières mesures
annoncées donc aujourd'hui par martine
aubry damien thévenot jean-jacques le
garrec gérard morvan et radiologues une
spécialité dans le collimateur de
martine aubry depuis ce matin les
radiologues contre coûté à la sécurité
sociale et sans justification apparente
il devrait donc être sanctionné la
baisse de leurs honoraires est fortement
envisagée le gouvernement veut réaliser
450 millions de francs d'économies ce
spécialiste n'est pas contre à condition
que cela ne se fasse pas sous la menace
fait pas d'économies en 10 ans on va
taper sur la tête des gens va réduire
les honoraires en fait on a mis en en
faisant de la qualité - et de qualité -
et de qualité bruno deloffre est tout à
fait d'accord pourtant ce généraliste
s'oppose à son collègue radiologue
sur un point il faut maintenir le
système des sanctions financières en cas
de dépassement des prescriptions
l'effet est dissuasif pour ce
généraliste la forte augmentation des
dépenses de santé des radiologues et des
biologistes doit être totalement assumée
qui vont les médecins conventionnés on
est responsable des dépenses que l'on
induit vis-à-vis de la société vis-à-vis
des assurés sociaux
la moindre des choses c'est
effectivement d'assumer cette
responsabilité nous manque les
radiologues ne veuille pas l'assumer ça
les regarde
le gouvernement se donne plusieurs
semaines pour trouver un accord avec
l'ensemble du corps médical
au delà il prendra des mesures
autoritaires pour remplir ses objectifs
3 milliards de francs d'économies pour
1998 un jeune camionneur de quimper en
bretagne s'est tué samedi dernier au
volant de sa fourgonnette en fouillant à
l'intérieur du véhicule les gendarmes
ont trouvé une note manuscrit de son
employeur lui précisant les vitesses qui
devait adopter pendant sa tournée des
vitesses supérieures à celles
normalement autorisé l'employeur a été
mise en examen pour homicide
involontaire et d'une manière générale
dans le secteur du transport routier les
manquements à la loi sont trop nombreux
albums nicosie gens veulent un panneaux
arrachés et les traces de la sortie de
route sur près de 200 mètres
le jeune livreur âgé de 22 ans a perdu
le contrôle de son véhicule dans ce
virage de la voie express près de
quimper dans la camionnette accidentée
les policiers ont trouvé une note
manuscrite de l'employeur précisant les
vitesses à adopter avec des pointes
supérieures aux 110 km autorisé estime
le procureur de la république de quimper
qui a mis en examen l'employeur pour
homicide involontaire
l'entreprise employait deux personnes
dans ce pavillon près de nantes une
secrétaire et le jeune livreur la
fourgonnette n'était pas équipé d'un
disque est acquis graphique impossible
donc de vérifier sa vitesse au moment de
l'accident
mais cela n'est pas illégal le mouchard
n'est pas obligatoire en dessous de 3
tonnes 5 ce qui distingue livreurs des
routiers c'est un secteur où les
salariés restent peu parce que les
conditions de travail sont telles qu'on
pensait qu'on repense mais on y restera
donc c'est relativement difficile
deuxièmement ce sont des toutes petites
entreprises
et troisièmement c'est la loi de la
jungle
si le mec ne fait pas un truc il est
foutu à la lourde en de caunes erreurs
on va voir de plus c'est terminé suite
aux mouvements sociaux de l'hiver
dernier le ministère des transports
cherche à faire évoluer les conditions
de travail des livreurs
mais ce n'est pas simple il faudra
convaincre les tenants du libéralisme
dans l'europe des quinze qui s'opposent
à un durcissement de la législation
après les problèmes de contamination
radioactive des convois de déchets en
gare de valognes dans la manche qui se
rendait à l' usine de la hague
c'était à la fin du mois d'avril edf et
la sncf avaient par mesure de sécurité
arrêter ce type de transport le feu vert
a été donné aujourd'hui à la reprise de
l'acheminement des déchets radioactifs
non pas un lag mais à la centrale
nucléaire de bugey dans l'ain
reportage josé blanc la pierre alice
betula centimètre par centimètre cette
technicienne ddf va désormais passer
neuf heures au lieu de 2 à faire ce
qu'elle appelle du dépistage
l'ensemble du chargement va ainsi être
soumis au passage de la chiffonnette
wagons et containers de combustible usé
compris autre nouveauté un radiamètre
d'un laboratoire indépendante pour
déceler la moindre poussière radioactive
nous prenons toutes ces précautions
parce que il est apparu que il y avait
un problème de propreté aucun moment
comme on l'a dit la santé n'était en
cause mais nous avons pris conscience
qu'il était absolument nécessaire que
l'on trouvera est complètement propre
alerté il ya deux mois par la présence
de wagons contaminer la sncf
inquiète pour la santé de ses cheminots
avaient cessé et transports de
combustibles irradiés
aujourd'hui les voyages reprennent le
client et df semble avoir fourni toutes
les garanties
si ce matin je n'avais pas reçu
le certificat de garantie de non
continuation de cela nous ne serions pas
l'usagé arrivés avec leurs instruments
ces intrus joue les trouble-fête n'est
pas question pour eux de faire leur
propre mesure répond le directeur
selon ces écologistes un wagon même
nettoyé de prêts ne suffit pas le
chargement dégage une irradiation
dangereuse pour la santé de ceux qui
s'en approche de trop près il faut
indiquer aux cheminots qu'ils doivent
passer le moins de temps possible non
seulement au contact des transports mais
même à plusieurs mètres
puisque ces champs de radiations font
extrêmement pénétrant se sent qu'on voit
sillonne la france chaque année
destination des centres de la hague où
chaque centrale nucléaire ces retraités
sans combustibles usés c'est le début de
la fin d'un serpent de mer après
l'accord passé entre la france et la
russie va commencer l'examen de tous
ceux qui sont en possession de ces
fameux emprunts russes qui n'ont jamais
été remboursés pour cause de révolution
bolchévique pour autant tout n'est pas
simple dominique barrouche josef fojtik
brand bas chez les porteurs d'emprunts
russes
aujourd'hui commence le recensement de
tous ceux qui détiennent ces titres émis
avant 1917 par l'état ou par une société
russe
mais avant d'aller chez le percepteur où
a lieu l'opération
ils viennent d'abord vérifier auprès
d'experts que les papiers retrouvés dans
les greniers sont authentiques
à l'heure actuelle on estime entre 200
milles et 400 mille le nombre des petits
porteurs qui vont se partager les 2
milliards et demi de francs versés par
la russie c'est pourquoi les
associations aimerait limiter le
recensement aux seuls titres émis en
france
c'est un petit peu plus du leader
et si tel est le cas et si des millions
de titres venait presque frauduleusement
de suisse de belgique ou de même de
moscou parce que la mafia russe se doit
pouvoir faire la faire évidemment ça
réduirait d'autant la part des petits
porteurs français à bercy on veut au
contraire procéder au recensement le
plus large possible
après seulement sera élaboré un projet
de loi précisant qui sera indemnisé et
combien encore limite t on à portée de
l'accord franco rigide titres sont
dû à leur propriétaire et rien ne les
empêche ensuite de les conserver et or
les relations étatiques de justifier
auprès du gouvernement russe d'un
remboursement il s'agit bien d'une
indemnisation et non pas d'un
remboursement de ses emprunts
les porteurs d'emprunts russes auront
donc attendu 80 ans pour une simple
indemnisation le remboursement lui n'est
toujours pas à l'ordre du jour
c'est pratiquement à l'unanimité que
sénateurs et députés réunis en congrès à
versailles ont dit oui à la révision de
la constitution sur le statut de la
nouvelle calédonie il permettra la mise
en place de nouvelles institutions
locales là bas et à terme une éventuelle
indépendance jean baptiste prédalles i
look at you c'est un congrès à leur
calédoniennes dans les couloirs du
château de versailles ont salué d'abord
les signataires des accords de nouméa de
mai dernier et sur l'avenir de leur
territoire
c'est d'abord eux qui s'exprime jean
kuete livres 11 ans
dans la paix
vrai que c'est
une nationalité panther
et des pouvoirs accrus sur bull dans ces
moments là on pense à tous les
tout le combat de nos anciennes tout le
travail dans des conditions difficiles 2
depuis l'est la suppression de l'un des
chemins où la délégation du fln caisse
était dans les tribunes pour voir
modifier la constitution dans quinze ou
vingt ans à référendum décidera sur
place de l'avenir la nouvelle calédonie
avec un corps électoral spécifique une
exception assumée par tous mais c'est
aussi et avant tout un acte politique
majeur auquel l'ampleur de votre
adhésion donnera une force et une valeur
irremplaçable
à peine le temps pour les participants
au premier congrès de la nouvelle
législature ne satisfaire au rituel du
timbre sorti pour l'occasion
si le congrès n'a duré que quelques
heures à versailles c'est aussi parce
que sur la nouvelle calédonie il y avait
un large consensus
au delà du droit
notre gouvernement et notre parlement
ont réussi à établir un nouvel qu'elle
nie la paix et la promesse d'un avenir
où nous pouvons dans
une tradition de la nation qui a hérité
du discours de brazzaville du général de
gaulle qui est d'accompagner les
populations à sociale avance vers leur
pays
logiquement après deux heures de
discours la constitution est modifiée
par 827 points contre 31 une révision
constitutionnelle sans surprise comme
s'il s'agissait de solder des comptes 12
de part et d'autre aujourd'hui en tout
cas la nouvelle calédonie a cessé d'être
un enjeu conflictuel de la politique
intérieure française
l'actualité internationale la
catastrophe qui touche l'état de floride
aux états unis prend chaque jour un peu
plus d'ampleur on en est à 180 milles
hectares de forêt brûlés et en est fini
team le seul espoir des pompiers c'est
l'arrivée d'un orage dans les 48 heures
en attendant pour sauver les biens et
les personnes on a fait appel à des
pilotes d'hélicoptères bombardiers d'eau
qui prennent tous les risques sur place
dominique derda chaque jour le même
scénario le matin tout est calme puis le
vent se lève et attise les braises
en quelques minutes les flammes
atteignent la cime des arbres pour les
pompiers au sol il n'y a plus rien à
faire qu'à se tenir à l'écart et
observer l'impressionnant spectacle
le vent est le pire ennemi des soldats
du feu l'allier quand tout paraît perdue
c'est l'hélicoptère
les affaires et le chef des pilotes ne
devrait pas arriver avant encore trois
ou quatre jours en attendant ce sont eux
qui vont devoir faire tomber la pluie
ces hommes et ces femmes venues de tous
les etats-unis
appelés au secours par l'état de floride
comme travail c'est super on s'amuse
vraiment beaucoup
vous voulez gagner beaucoup d'argent
c'est pas terrible
en revanche si vous cherchez un truc
excitant chaque jour différents alors on
gagne laventure comme elles disent c'est
pour 50 ans de leur au grand maximum se
cramponnait des semaines durant à bord
d'appareils aussi étrange que cette grue
volante transformée en gigantesque pompe
aspirante dans ses soutes il ya soeur
jusqu'à dix mille litres d'eau mais ce
n'est qu'une goutte dans un océan de
flammes
il faut à ces hélicoptères faire des
dizaines de rotation pour parvenir à
ralentir ou à détourner la progression
du peu
alors seulement les bulldozer pourront
retourner dans la forêt et les pompiers
pas à pas pied à pied défendre une à une
les maisons qui s'y trouvait qui n'ont
pas encore brûlé en plo reid la guerre
du peu est bien loin d'être gagnée vague
de chaleur et incendies également dans
le sud de l'europe en grèce et aussi en
sardaigne sur ces images l'italien
général cône est actuellement de très
fortes chaleurs en sardaigne ce sont
4000 hectares de forêts qui sont partis
en fumée
des centaines de milliers de personnes
risquent de mourir de faim dans les
trois prochains mois une grande partie
de la population du sud soudan un pays
en guerre depuis 15 ans maintenant
chrétiens et animistes du sud contre les
islamistes arabes du nord une guerre
oubliée qui a déjà fait plus d'un
million de victimes
aujourd'hui ce sont les organisations
humanitaires qui dénonce une situation
dramatique aggravée par la décision du
régime islamiste de khartoum de gêner
l'acheminement de toute forme d' aide à
ces populations reportage dorothée
olliéric pascal quint nous sommes au sud
soudan une région très difficile d'accès
le régime islamiste de khartoum se méfie
des visiteurs
c'est donc le plus souvent
clandestinement humanitaires et
journalistes font leur travail dans
cette zone de guerre où sept cent mille
personnes sont touchées par la famine
au détour d'un chemin en marché ou du
moins ce qu'il en reste
on n'a rien à manger ce qu'on essaye de
vendre ce sont quelques racines et à
cause de la guerre et de la sécheresse
on n'a rien d'autre à manger
à une vingtaine de kilomètres de la
rumba qu avant la guerre cent mille
habitants aujourd'hui des ruines peuplés
de réfugiés
on n'est jamais prêt à affronter le
spectacle de la famine la réalité tient
en ces quelques images
il peut être pour eux le plus difficile
c'est réapprendre à manger
5 c'est la fin rien d'autre il souffre
parce qu'elle n'a rien dans l'estomac
il n'est pas malade c'est la fin tous ne
pourront pas être sauvés faute de
nourriture en quantités suffisantes
depuis quelques semaines il pleut et
l'herbe est redevenu verte mais en 12
ans de sécheresse ils n'ont rien pu
planter et sont désormais totalement
dépendants de l'aide humanitaire
le secours catholique distribuer 6 des
animaux mais aussi des semences il y à
des largages aériens des d'humanitaires
mais c'est loin d'ici
et en attendant la prochaine récolte ils
n'ont rien et mange le peu qu'ils
trouvent dans la forêt ce que nous
voulons c'est un soudan juste et unifiée
chance soldats de l'armée populaire de
libération du soudan
ces catholiques combattent le régime
militaro-islamiste du général omar el
béchir depuis 1983 la charia la loi
islamique est en vidéo dans ton pays
ces rebelles se battent pour la liberté
religieuse et culturelle
c'est une politique d'extermination
pratiqué par le régime islamiste
ils utilisent toutes les méthodes y
compris larmes de la famille il prive la
population du sud de nourriture de
médicaments et même d'eau potable autour
de l'église détruite sont enfouis des
dizaines de mines antipersonnel mais
qu'importe c'est dimanche et ils
viennent pour prier
demande à dieu la fin de la guerre plus
de points aussi
c'est vital pour nous de prier on le
fait tous les dimanches un même quand il
y à des bombardements au sud soudan les
enfants meurent dans le silence et la
communauté internationale elle détourne
les yeux
peut-être impuissante peut être
indifférente le lourdes peines de prison
requise par le procureur à madrid contre
les deux principaux accusés dans le
procès des gal ces groupes
antiterroristes espagnoles d'une police
parallèle qui luttait contre les
terroristes basques de letea le
professeur a donc demandé 23 ans de
prison contre l'ex ministre de
l'intérieur socialiste josé barrionuevo
et son secrétaire d'état à la sécurité
en algérie alors que l'arabisation entre
dans les faits l'un des moyens de lutter
pour la liberté d'expression reste
là-bas la chanson le chanteur lounès
matoub ou bien de le payer de sa vie
moins de deux semaines après son
assassinat sa dernière cassette est
sorti aujourd'hui caroline d'audrin bel
eric rihs temps
ses boutons
le dernier disque de lounès matoub tout
le monde l'attendait
à peine est-il sorti que déjà il est
devenu difficile à trouver chez sauviat
la plus connue des boutiques de musique
orientale
il s'est vendu 615 c'est en deux jours
c'est un petit effet à ce qu'il y ait
assez de poèmes à présent que le courage
la langue démission si vous voulez
traiter cet album là vous verrez tous
les gens qui viennent aujourd'hui qui
monte monte monte à paris où on a géré
la 700 spécialement à rien pour
continuer encore la lutte pour dire on
est toujours là et on se souviendra non
c'est vraiment sur le bureau du
producteur du chanteur kabyle les
destins de la maquette du dernier disque
cet enregistrement
lounès matoub l'avait décidé très vite
en un moins ils avaient tous conçus tout
écrit comme s'il y avait urgence à
s'exprimer après ça c'était un gamin
qu'il préparait une mauvaise passe voilà
ce que moi je comprends pas le cas bien
sûr et j'ai l'impression qu'ils étaient
c'était un esprit tu vas voir tu vas on
va en parler ce qui est en train de
faire il s'était dit regardez nous
dévoiler l'ensemble du contenu de ce
disque
et dans ce cas fait longtemps parmi ses
amis qu'il a écrit la plupart de ces
gens sens celle qui marque les esprits
c'est la reprise de l'hymne algérie y as
il en a modifié les paroles et remplacé
révolution par trahison au niveau du
texte
il traverse
il traverse tout nous tous leurs que le
valais peuvent avoir aujourd'hui le nes
maktoum était un poète mais aussi un
militant
il rêvait d'une algérie pluriculturelle
la dernière phrase de son disque elle et
pour ses amis kabyle unissez vous avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
un hooligan allemands soupçonnés d'avoir
pris part à l'agression du gendarme
français à lens a été arrêté aujourd'hui
à hanovre en allemagne inculpé de
tentative de meurtre il a reconnu se
trouver s'être trouvé sur les lieux au
moment de l'agression mais il nie pour
l'instant farouchement toute
participation
la coupe du monde de football maintenant
avec donc ce soir notre invité pelé le
dernier carré se prépare aux
demi-finales l'équipe de france s'est
entraîné aujourd'hui à clairefontaine
effectif est au complet
il n'y a plus de blessés yann lavoix
andré germa
il y avait 50 caméras de télévision ce
matin pour recueillir les impressions
des joueurs français justement
impressionné par ce déploiement de force
internationale mais qui leur permet de
mieux réaliser encore qu'ils sont demi
finaliste d'une coupe du monde
baloch c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ça a
dépassé les limites je crois que c'est
moi qu'on va très bien qu'on est là
quand même
en demi finale de coupe du monde donc
c'est vrai que lente aux airs 20 caméras
malgré cet environnement médiatique il
demeure dans leur bulle de verdure les
français à clairfont tendu ils sont
conscients bien sûr que le toit du monde
est à portée de crampons mais ils sont
encore loin de vouloir comparer leurs
aventures à celle de leurs aînés
je ne comprends pas vraiment compte que
on est on est quand même entre dans
l'histoire des grandes équipes
françaises moisson se rend pas compte
parce que ça fait un objectif qui est la
finale et on est ensemble que cette
équipe a le potentiel
en suède il ya 40 ans les journalistes
se bousculent est déjà pour
photographier fontaine au pied en tenue
lui et les bleus d'aujourd'hui ont vu et
revu ces images de 58 et surtout celle
de 82 et 86 les deux défaites contre
l'allemagne
et bien aujourd'hui on peut dire que
l'équipe de 98 a fait aussi bien mais
peut-on comparer et enfiler les
chaussures d'un copain ou d'un platini
il faut pas vivre avec le passé ça
malheureusement ça sa part scènes seront
passés de l'équipe de france mais nous
il faut vivre au jour le jour
à l'heure actuelle de la chose d'être
données signalent mais bon vous savez la
demi finale c'est bien mais bon c'est
pas c'est pas la finalité il y a une
détermination dans l'oeil de thuram et
dans celui de ses copains qui nous fait
penser que cette génération de français
pourrait être la première à s'approprier
le sacré graal la coupe du monde à
condition toutefois de ne pas
sous-estimer la croatie parce qu'elle a
battu l'allemagne
c'est vrai que c'est une nation à ces
nouvelles vin dans le monde du football
mais y'a qu'à voir les joueurs qui
composent cette équipe là qui évolue
pratiquement dans tous les plus grands
clubs étrangers européens pour
s'apercevoir qu'ils ont une grande
qualité d'abord footballistique
individuelle et depuis ce mondial ils
ont fait preuve aussi d'une grande force
collective qui leur permettent à mon
avis de poser des problèmes pratiques
aux mains toutes les équipes du monde
alors tout le monde devra jouer serré
les onze sur le terrain les 80000 dans
les tribunes et les quelques millions de
français qui rêvent de cette finale ont
demandé son pronostic appeler les
adversaires des bleus maintenant dans
leur retraite de vittel ils sont
apparemment assez décontracté mais il ne
faudrait pas croire qu'il se contente
d'avoir atteint la demi finale florent
gautreau philippe deslandes
sous le soleil exactement dans les
transats tranquillement à vittel on a
inventé une nouvelle expression détendu
comme un croate qui va jouer une
demi-finale champion du monde des
communications longue distance
spécialiste du ping pong en terrasse les
croates prépare en toute décontraction
le match le plus important de leur jeune
histoire
des messieurs très tranquille
disponibles comme boban affable comme
blasé beach un blaser vite ch toutefois
plus inquiet qu'hier ne sont pas nerveux
ils sont même très relax mais moi je
suis particulièrement nerveux et inquiet
attention les manoeuvres manipulations
et autres intoxications ont commencé
tous les observateurs venus examiner les
croates à l'entraînement en ont été pour
leurs frais
c'est l'équipe b celle des remplaçants
qui a amusé la galerie sur le stade
municipal
lazovic le rusé s'étaient échappés
pendant ce temps avec les titulaires
dans le parc de l'hôtel les princes du
dribble ont frappé le roi du contre-pied
a encore changé de discours peut-être
pour tromper l'ennemi
j'ai besoin ni reine l'accepté pas parce
qu'ils sont très concrètement qu'est ce
que vous pensez qu est-ce qu il donne
l'impression des signes de crispation
bien difficile à discerner les croates
cachent leur jeu ça devient dangereux
après beaucoup de farniente et quelques
exercices balle au pied les croates vont
maintenant se retirer dans leurs hôtels
c'est leur dernière nuit ici à vittel
avant le jour j
une nuit pour se reposer bien sûr mais
une nuit aussi pour rêver à un nouvel
exploit contre les français pelé bonsoir
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors première question qui nous
concerne tous les téléspectateurs
français comment jugez vous les
performances de l'équipe de france
depuis le début de la coupe du monde je
voudrais vous remercier je suis bien
content d'être avec vous ce à dos
foncez voir ce que je pensais
l'équipe de france sans aucun doute et
c'est une des meilleures équipes de
cette coupe du monde et la joue beaucoup
plus au ray rend fou pas pour gagner et
ça c'est le jeu le public et c'est pour
cela que la france est arrivé où elle
est certains lui reprochent de ne pas
marqué à ses débuts par exemple contre
l'italie oui pauvre peuple qui à
l'important c'est que la france a créé
beaucoup de pauvres douar 2e but if je
vois tous les matchs j'analyse la france
a créé presque cinq occasions de jeu de
deux buts par les incidents le ballon
n'est pas rentré mais alors qu'elle est
calé le parmi les joueurs français ce
qui vous ont le plus impressionné
parmi les onze je pense que tout son
sens en très grande forme
mais déjà il c'est vraiment un joueur
extraordinaire
c'est vraiment du hameau si c'est un bon
joueur
quels sont les joueurs que je vive et
j'ai eu une bonne impression une grande
gêne 10 avec eric ritter et oui dans
jeunes joueurs tout le moins de deux
heures et qui a un avenir devant lui et
c'est une voix équipe alors là la france
va rencontrer on va parler dans un
instant du brésil mais la france va
rencontrer la croatie mercredi soir
est-ce que vous pensez que les français
sont vraiment grand favori ou qu'il doit
faire attention quand favoris oui bien
sûr sans aucun doute mais c'est une
responsabilité très grande
l'équipe française
devoir de gagner la croatie c'est la
première fois qu'elle est qualifiée
c'est une équipe qui vient pour la
première fois à la coupe du monde mais
il ya une chose très importante voire
tout joueur de la croatie joue dans
l'équipe grandes équipes européennes et
il son expérience et son expérimenté
tous les pays et la france
c'est un jeu avec beaucoup de pression
avant de parler du brésil juste une
question est-ce que vous avez été très
étonné par l'élimination de l'allemagne
et de l'italie l'italie ça m'a surpris
oui l'allemagne non l'allemagne
n'avez vous pas vraiment une équipe très
très bonne n'irai pas potro de
créativité au milieu alors la surprise
avec l italie nous déçoit
alors on parle du brésil maintenant
demain soir donc la france de demain
soir sur france 2 par dont la première
demi finale brésil pays bas ce sera
marseille le brésilien s'entraîne à
toulon les brésiliens qui depuis le
début de la compétition ont marqué
beaucoup de buts mais ont de véritables
problèmes défensifs reportage matuchet
roger motte le quart du brésil devant la
foule sous bonne escorte
les tribunes sont pleines le service
d'ordre aux aguets les photographes vie
c'est derrière leurs objectifs des
journalistes prêtent à s'époumoner en
direct
marseille dont encore deux jours après
son bracelet dans notre cour il ne
s'agit en fait que d'un simple
entraînement le brésil de ronaldo contre
le brésil de bebeto mais personne ne
boude son plaisir
pourquoi votre rôle ici
chauffer
bah c'est de surveiller un kosovar s'est
pas de verdure
on a profité de l'occasion que notre
hiérarchie nous a donné une autorisation
d sub l'entraînement donc
c'est une occasion tu peux pas couper
qu'on verra peut-être pas dans notre vie
donc en profiter mais si vous avez tous
un poster ou
l'annoncé est
des jeux car demain dès 11 d'abdos pour
ronaldo peut-être la photo du jour
carlos travail pour l'équivalent de
l'équipe au brésil quarante pages sont
envoyés chaque jour de francs des moins
qu'on en oublie ville va
jouer contre les pays bas les personnes
ne travaillent pas à l'après midi pour
regarder
le match que ce match très important
pour ce match d'entraînement les jaunes
ont gagné 4 1 contre les oranje mais
demain la véritable équipe du pays bas
devraient se montrer plus coriaces alors
question difficile pour demain alors je
suppose que vous croyez dans les chances
du brésil mais ce que vous pensez qu'ils
sont vraiment favori de ce match
op ou confiant mais j'avais confiance
dans l'équipe du brésil ou parce que le
brésil a des joueurs expérimentés et
c'est le champion du monde
la hollande la france ce sont les deux
meilleures équipes de compil de
championnat mondial du brésil est
différente de celle de la france parce
que la france va jouer avec une équipe
défensif le brésil va jouer avec une
équipe qui attaque et ça je crois qu'ils
se fait que nous ayons devant avoir peur
faire attention
la hollande va respecter le brésil mais
c'est un jeu difficile pour le brésil
je pense que le brésil à deux joueurs
individuels comme ronaldo qui courent
jouer sauf erreur c'est le valdo qui à
faire des bébés at il ya bebeto et le
brésil a des joueurs qui peuvent changer
les équilibres de la du mac
mais comme équipe en tant qu'équipe la
hollande c'est une équipe plus organisée
mais je crois que le brésil peut alors
d'une manière générale vous avez vu
beaucoup de matchs depuis le début de
cette coupe du monde
quel est votre jugement sur l'évolution
du football actuel quels sont les par
exemple on a dit que le football
africain avait été décevant quelles sont
les équipes qui vous ont déçu qu est-ce
que ce foule ce mondial vous a déçu est
ce que vous vous êtes enthousiasme et je
pense que cette coupe du monde c'était
une coupe du monde à un niveau très très
bon mais le très bon niveau mieux que la
dernière coupe du monde de techniquement
de la coupe du monde italie même nous
avons plus de plus de 3,3 moyenne de
deux buts par match donc c'est une coupe
du monde avec beaucoup de buts mais la
surprise a été un nigeria les nigériens
j'attendais pas l'espagne qu'on
attendait qu'ils allaient y un peu plus
d'argent
l'angleterre aussi qui est sorti et pour
moi l'italie que j'attendais mais
j'avais dit que le brésil hollande et la
france préférait à la finale ça j'avais
dit je pense que je me suis trompé
uniquement avec la croatie qu'elle est
qu'elle est si ce n'est le fait que vous
êtes aujourd'hui plus âgés qu'en 1958
est ce que vous préférez le football
vous préféreriez joue au football où
aujourd'hui où à l'époque où vous avez
joué au football j'ai vu les deux faces
j'ai reçu je vis ce football avec
beaucoup de joie et bonheur et cette
phase cet autre phase belle 50 qui passe
de 40 ans maintenant palerme ombrie but
de football londres a dit hier 7 en
trois périodes si c'est une période puis
ferry plus voir qui est financièrement
intéressante les joueurs
sinon 20 millions paul et je vais vous
demander à un pronostic quand même pour
terminer donc la finale c'est entre kehl
l'équipe et quelle équipe
walker bon je pense que la finale du
siècle voilà ça serait brésil et france
j'essaie que je le satan c'est ce qui
m'a manqué redemande mais le football ce
n'est pas ici je veux tous encore
davantage finale brésil france et qui la
gagne bon allez ma volonté que la femme
est difficile à une tradition de coupe
du monde de squash
parmi les quatre qui sont à la fin
seulement le brésil a été le camp de
champion la france ait déjà la
possibilité tout près mais bon ça n'a
jamais réussi c'est très difficile de
pouvoir parler mais d'abord la france
doit gagner la croatie et le brésil au
lendemain merci en tout cas
et bravo pour votre participation merci
d'être avec nous ce soir
merci beaucoup merci à vous demain soir
et mercredi soir il n'y aura pas que les
stars du football mondial qui fouleront
les pelouses de marseille et de saint
denis en lever de rideau des gamins
venus de france mais aussi du brésil
d'afrique du sud du mexique disputeront
leur coupe du monde celle de l'amitié
alexandre kara jean-paul chaud c'est
qu'ils viennent de la banlieue de
johannesburg des faubourgs de rio ou des
alentours de l'île ces gamins là on fait
un rêve qui s'est réalisé un rêve de
foot vivre leur propre coupe du monde
cet après midi à bagneux brésil afrique
du sud mexique et france sont venus
affronter les équipes locales
ils ont amené des ballons de l'ambiance
aussi
lorsqu'on est moment lorsqu'on est gamin
dans un quartier en rêve
on rêve de boutons rêve de ronaldo en
rêve de zinédine zidane lui enlève de
plein d'autres et c'est tout simplement
essayé de que nos quartiers aussi fils
participer à ce rêve depuis quelques
jours ces footballeurs en herbe
s'entraîne acteurs fontaine où il côtoie
les grands de l'équipe de france de quoi
faire naître des ambitions
je pense qu'un jour moi aussi je jouerai
la vraie coupe du monde
mais avant cela les quatre équipes
sélectionnées joueront les avant-matches
des vrais demi finales à marseille et à
saint denis nous sommes vraiment très
heureux de jouer avant nos idoles et
avec l'aide de dieu j'espère que nous
allons remporter ce match
j'espère aussi que l'équipe du brésil
qui jouera après nous va gagner pour
aller en finale demain les brésiliens
rencontreront les français des petits
bleus mois sur deux que leurs aînés ça
va être difficile ça va être difficile
parce qu'on les avait joués et pour
l'instant gagné leur match
l'autre demi finale opposera l'afrique
du sud au mexique les vainqueurs
ouvriront le bal avant la finale des
grands
le 12 juillet à saint denis en banlieue
qui tombe maintenant à l'instant les
stades pour la fin des collections du
prêt-à-porter masculin de l'été 99 un
mélange très contrastée de raffinement
pour les uns de provocation pour les
autres nicole cornu langlois l'ukba
chauffer
c'est une petite poche avec fermeture
éclair que nous montre ce monsieur et
nous ne sommes pas un spectacle actuel
des folies berchère mais sur le podium
de thierry mugler qui habille tout de
même ces sommes en total jean
ils peuvent aussi tressé d'affaires plus
sérieuse en complet classique
parfaitement coupé pour dior côté rétro
pour fin de siècle avec cinq garçons
dans le vent
imaginé par patrick lavoie dans un décor
citadins cvs dans l'ain estivale mais
les deux soient souplesse et fluidité
des tenues de week end une collection
coordonnables est déclinable à l'infini
selon l'humeur à l'opposé les voyous de
jean paul gaultier se préparent pour des
chemins plus marginaux col ouvert et
relevé jean retroussé et gillet lingerie
le costume trois pièces et revisitée ils
se portent sans chemise ou avec chemise
de la même couleur
mélange de provocation et de maîtrise
qui font le charme et le succès de jean
paul gaultier
laniel auteuil et francis huster sont
venus pour la collection lanvin de
dominic moore le tir pantalon large et
fluide sous weis 2 longiligne silhouette
formelle ou informelle selon l'air du
temps pour travailler le vendredi et
partir le soir en week-end de la chemise
se fait veste ou inversement le smoking
se portent avec des sandales et la soie
et le lin s'allie avec noblesse
chez kenzo pureté du blanc et des lignes
si le judoka les ceintures ne sont que
des liens les saharienne à quatre poches
accompagne des pantalons courts
fluidité des tuniques transparence des
chemises
un air de jeunesse une force naturelle
tony dynamique pour le dernier était du
ciel
les plus anciens s'en souviendront
l'acteur et chanteur américain aaron
rodgers vient de mourir à l'âge de 86
ans sur son cheval il avait parcouru le
far west dans une célèbre série
télévisée noir et blanc il anima
également de très nombreux shows à la
télévision américaine
chantait également la musique des cobras
avant nous quitter le rappel du
principal titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi le déficit de la sécurité sociale
un nouveau plan pour éviter les
dérapages
les premières mesures mesures visent
certains spécialistes ou des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
dans un instant la météo se vide avant
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur notre chaîne bonsoir à l'abonné de